why is your glove off dude you know what
if was being nasty earlier guys tried
I'm taking order and I was like oh did
we what area and she was like just put
it in tone it down oh she was like oh
wait someone's really horny today oh
yeah
and Orion's was sniffing Ishmael Shmi al
[Music]
well I really wish Joe was here for this
one because he he has a special place in
his heart for this particular place that
we're about to talk about horn Holly oh
no no think a little cleaner this is
like innocent Joe's heart who needed
love as a child
where did he want cheese steak okay Oh
love Chuck E Cheese Chuck E Cheese we
all have that soft spot right yes I love
trash every part of our chests pizza in
the world
amen brother yes Joel would be on
pornhub until you geez that's weird but
yeah so I mean Chuck E Cheese there are
reports now guys hold hold yourselves
ready yeah you're sitting down right
everyone know I heard about they're
going under they see almost 1 billion
dollars in debt no and they're on the
brink of bankruptcy and on the brink
closing completely location when things
open up we should all go and like get
final-round kid that we can that we cool
with us we really go with one kid one at
all right they have all in but at five
adults with just one for me ya know we
get a kid for this we gotta get a couple
I know we can get away with it someone
has a birthday party there we can all go
in go get [ __ ] up go there pizza then
you get a stamp for that party oh okay
okay okay I'm down I'm so down I'm
actually down yeah sometimes we say
we're down for these remember that down
this and I want to actually very very
down if
they can make it through this tough time
there okay I actually have quite a few
things to tell you about chuck-e-cheese
or cho so that's like the first like the
main one that's like right now in those
headlines and all that right so they are
asking lenders for a 200 million u.s.
dollar loan to keep the business going
because when coronavirus hit they had to
close all 610 of its locations across
the 47 states and they had to lay out
17,000 employees and also what they
ended up doing to keep the business
running which a lot of people are like
what what he did to go well all they
sort of have that that's so smart yeah
so what they did is they created this
new company called Pasquale's pizza and
they went on all the food delivery apps
and they branded this whole restaurant
as if it's like a whole new brand new
restaurant and then that's when people
started discovering like people who
loved the pizza they were like wait a
second this is a [ __ ] familiar pizza
so there's one lady one time she texted
the her food delivery person and she was
like by any chance did this come from
with chucky cheese and she was like yeah
it was really weird like there was like
in the chucky cheese restaurant there
was like the Pasquale's Pizza logo on
the window and so that's what they had
been doing is like kind of like a lot of
people feel like deceived a bit where
it's like just stir Shane Dawson's video
was this piss video oh yeah I'm
guaranteeing because I mean obviously
you don't really know how order for a
cheese pizza on postman even if that
didn't come out
but you're wrong people I think that's
why they [ __ ] up well yeah if you are
known to be they were afraid though
because of that so I didn't watch that
video yeah that's also like if there was
Disneyland churros on post meats that's
gonna do way better than Disney knows
churros right I'm like what the [ __ ] is
Pasquale's the pizza guy the I don't
know that I just
but if the mouse was on the box then I
would have got it people felt the seeds
because they felt like they were
supporting like a local
I know how we're just high enough camera
about how I don't like pizza here cheese
pizzas really yeah general no I love you
too but there's not that much out here
that's that good but I know like I was
one of the top ones better than Papa
John's better than Domino's Shani cheese
was amazing
I remember one time me my boy we were
like just like sophomores in high school
and we were just gonna hang out at the
mall you know in your [ __ ] you can't
do [ __ ] but just go to the mall and we
didn't know it was like a Memorial Day
weekend so the whole mall was closed but
Chuckie Cheese was open so we had
already had our parents like drop us off
to chill at them off like 6 hours you
know and we're like [ __ ] what we're
gonna do and like Oh Chuckie Cheese open
but we were too old to go inside so we
went in and we were allowed to order
pizza to go and we just sat in the
parking lot of a Chuckie Cheese eating
pizza and it was amazing but they come
like the mix mist a mix and matched
shape sir what oh no no not that I
remember
yeah Damon Buster's isn't the same
that's what it's like it is fun though
it's fun I like drinking there and stuff
but then sometimes like maybe just have
more fun as a kid and everything is bad
yeah did you guys ever do that in
between the the DeeZee Discovery Zone
it literally shat on Chuckie Cheese from
in my opinion yeah marketed towards more
like older than Chuckie Cheese almost
like TV like junior high twinsies teens
the spotlight really young
really I didn't even know that it was
like active kids I think I think it's
like the mighty kids group like an
indoor playground to the match just like
tunnels ensure they can climb funky fun
my favorite thing that I miss to this
day is like the Rolly thingies like me
too are you kidding me that's my rolling
it was like massages they were rainbow
rolling my favorite thing what my
fingers would get caught in there yeah
that was dangerous but yeah or my hair
nothing is better than Andretti's in
Florida though that was sick with that
doll
it's this place that we went to after
playlist life where you just straight up
what does it go kart racing Android or
go kart racing cousin dready is like a
Formula One yeah yeah yeah with food yep
plush games drinks that was like sounds
like a golfing stuff for uh in in
torrenting doors and nicer and way nice
and like sick arcade machines not like
the old [ __ ] yeah I mean old shits cool
but it's not all dirty and VR [ __ ] too
well okay well that's tight would you
would you pay for like say cuz then I
remember when we had back home is like I
forgot the name of the place but it was
like buffets I also had like the same
stuff let's check your cheese oh the
pizza one yeah hybrids keep the paper
yeah yeah yeah so that's gonna be tough
there are different themes right well
like imagined isn't that had like say
you have to pay like an extra hundred
bucks but it's all day can just go play
on rides and go back to have a fancy
that's cool oh why didn't I yeah I'll be
tie it yeah I don't mind the lines
that's what sound like at Disneyland
it's like three hours all right
not as you get the fast path well we got
to do the VIP thing at Disney VIP dude
so we got VIP through maker at the time
it was amazing it was amazing it's like
what the celebrities getting [ __ ] they
have a private employee that like takes
you in a little group oh my god you like
skip all the lines you enter through the
back of the rides Oh
only or can you buy it well I asked
because I ended up keeping in contact
with that Disney employee that was
taking us around and I kind of like
inquired like how much it might be if I
just wanted to do that and it's a lot
like 10 or 40 I'd have forgot thousand
big it is a big difference but I just
don't remember I think it might be
40,000 what $40,000 whole year salary
that's it was [ __ ] awesome so you go
on Space Mountain like do you want to go
again and like yeah yeah yeah and like
see ya like it's so cool it's thousands
right thousands for how big of a group
cuz if you split it it was just me Jim
Rick Nikki and wasn't a big grip yeah it
wasn't it wasn't it was in a group say
okay well hold that before we we
continue with more awesome things like
Disneyland there's so much more about
chuck-e-cheese I gotta tell you geez you
know I'm just gonna tell you the origin
story first have you guys heard of the
origin story
it's a French rat that learns how to
make Pete fall into mutagen and then
became big joseph Donatello yeah that's
his friend [ __ ] Hitler mm-hmm okay
here it is ready I'm gonna read it
Chuckie Cheese grew up in an orphanage
called st. marinara
okay cuz he was an orphan Chuck did not
know his own birthday but loves
celebrating the birthdays of other
orphans in the orphanage he loved music
and games and he especially loved
singing happy birthday even though he'd
never hurt heard it sung to himself Oh
one day when Chuck grew up grew too old
to stay at the orphanage he moved to New
York City there he was sad lonely and
homeless he decided to sleep it's New
York
it's a pizzeria because he loved the
music from the radio and the smell of
pizza eventually he got caught by the
pizza shop owner who tried to kill him
oh the only thing that saved chuck was
his singing the second Surya owner
thought he had a great voice and
employed him to sing to his customers in
the restaurant on his first night up on
stage chuck was two of
to sing and kept getting booed long
story short he saw a boy with the
birthday crowd and couldn't help but
sing the crowd cheered and the pizzeria
became the most popular spot in town
forevermore perfect for families and
birthday parties didn't like singing at
first because it was never had a
birthday they're trying to get 200
million dollars with that story
sob story bro that's the way to do it no
that was the origin like since it's on
the Wikipedia page and like they
actually printed out a book years ago
kind of a cool story as the origin story
in that book two pizzas fate man like
what are the chances of being at full
with it marinara right so happened to be
at a pizzeria his best friend named
Pasquale like well he's pizza you know
how do you meet the purple gorilla yeah
favorite acid oh [ __ ] well it was just
on acid well yeah okay and the last
final thing I have to talk about Chuckie
Cheese here is that writes before Korona
hit they had expected to remodel over 80
location and be done by the end of 2019
oh they actually had gotten rid of the
animatronic robot band he had gotten rid
of the tokens as well so this is like no
tokens yeah no more tokens all the cards
now but it's not like Dave and Buster
where you have to like note it like you
have to pay for each game it's not like
that Tiffany's or like a wristband um
chucky cheese instead the parents load
up the amount of time kids could be
playing so many plays for a certain
amount of time and the parent just
reloads the time you get to you know yes
that's pretty cool don't get uh no more
tokens Wow so basically it's sicker than
ever before no [ __ ] please don't close I
want to go
but the cover to the image chronic ban
that classic part is like me out when I
was good they said Corona started
attitude cheese I would have believed it
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah it's the bat member of
the band that's what it is what is this
the purple gorilla I don't know how he
got his shirt on over his head he's the
drummer nobody ever remembers you don't
need it put a soda too
maybe like they took out the animatronic
band but they replaced it with like I
can like super smooth throw but no they
replace it with this dance floor that
when you step on it and lights up like I
want to be a kid right now and go there
cuz the other animatronic band it was I
had so many pictures of me crying they
said an animatronic band yes I should
scare the [ __ ] out of there's no picture
of a smiling kid next to it it's the
eyes yeah and also the mouth like why do
they have to make their mouth so huge
and because I made it in like the 80s
and then they just like this is this is
ever heard of five nights at Freddy's oh
my god yeah that's what I reminded me oh
that's what it's based off of isn't it
like I'm not sure so it's this video
game it's like a scary video game where
you're at the pretty much like a
different version of a pizza party
Chuckie Cheese called Freddy's and and
then so you're there at night and you're
pretty much trying to retrieve I don't
know something kind of a tronic
characters end up eating kids mm-hmm
it's [ __ ] scary
you're like a security guard and you got
to keep watch of these animatronics from
moving and then when they move you have
to be careful because like you got it
like constantly check the doors and if
you open the door on them like when the
animatronic is right outside then you
literally die [ __ ] scary fever dream
it is like they constantly do jump
scares I yeah like he's wanting me to
play no no my son wanna play that shrekt
one
[Music]
[Music]